okay
[Music]
all right Chrissy yeah Chrissy where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
Rhode Island
tell me about your family
um
judgmental family
um
Prejudice family
[Music]
I don't really know Mom or Dad
my father
um I've heard you in school huh how far
did you go in school ninth grade
why'd you quit so early
um
I don't know I got into a fight and got
my ass
the first week on the ninth grade
and I quit school
what'd you do after
quitting school
um kind of like just got involved with
some people that led me up to me in my
first baby daddy
and I met him and
um
oh it didn't really work out so well
how old were you when you had your first
child huh how old were you when you had
your friend I was 17 when I got pregnant
I was 18 and I had my first daughter mom
son
and I had
[Music]
a really nasty crack habit
and uh
three kids
and he was saying me
um
I lost my three kids
because he used to hit me
and I had a nasty drug problem
s
my life felt so normal back then
look
so I um
I ended up on the streets
homeless and uh
I met went silent to meetings and I met
my husband
and
I ended up with a adult habit
and honestly again and uh I got
um I ended up having this on
and got clean and got married and I
don't know my life was just so boring
like so boring
and
I don't know how to explain it
um the black sheep of your family
yeah
yeah I don't I don't understand how a
person can be so spiritual and it's so
important and crucial to the world and
like so many people
be so mean
and like
take everything from you
like your beauty
your feelings like who you are
like it makes no sense
like
I I know I have like a lot of I know it
sounds funny to say but like
I have so many vindictive people against
me and I haven't even done anything to
them like
they don't even have a chance to get to
know who I am
and like I'm a really sweet person and
like
I've been made out to look so ugly and
so vicious and so mean
and like they've taken everything from
me my kids my childhood my parents my
brothers my sisters my experiences like
my talents
like my like it's so embarrassing
why do you think you have so many
enemies huh why do you think you have so
many enemies
it's so hard to explain it's easy to
explain it's just like it's embarrassing
um
I don't know no Jesus Christ was like he
was crucified because of who he was
right
honestly
because of jealousy
because I I you really it's just a
spiritual thing and
it pisses me off that I keep it like put
my finger on it exactly do you think
you're misunderstood by most people
absolutely 100 completely what do you
think people most people don't
understand about you
um
my
um
just who I am my personality my softness
um
everything's sweet about a person that
you can actually think of
but it has been ruined
foreign
I don't know what to do with myself like
it hurts so bad to have like
to not be able to bring yourself
completely to explain yourself and get
understood and respected and like the
situation getting taken care of like I'm
searching and I'm searching like I have
faith
and I'm I'm flying the middle
and I have like so much understanding
and like I just want to fix everything
and make everything better like in every
area
but it's just so much [ __ ] in a way
and like I like I don't
like my my whole [ __ ] life is hacked
like completely I don't know how to else
put it
I just
I've been from Rhode Island
tall boy I have like a nasty case of
everyone knows that there's magic and
Witchcraft the Bible says it it says
don't do this right everyone that knows
the Bible it says that and like
these people were they were I think
everyone has a good understanding now
better to understand things that
um jealousy isn't the most nasty
vindictive disgusting way to be
I can only [ __ ] bring you out
and
oh I've been to Massachusetts
to try and see like
I'm a spiritual person and I love God
and I hate Gods so much
ugh
foreign
what brought you to Los Angeles
um trying to get this disgusting
disgusting wickedness off of me
and just like to bring me to power
to bring me to who I am
what do you think Los Angeles offers
that
someone else somewhere else might not
I don't I don't know anything really
about California except for Hollywood
and
that there's power here
I saw what kind of power
ah
disgusting beautiful power
um maybe more specific
from my understanding
um
to elevate
Beauty and feelings and experience on
another level you're being so vague
um
I don't know how to put it in words
I don't want to seem to like
seem like something that I'm not but I
am
um
like a lot of people don't want to put
it out there but I will
like I already told you I love God and I
love the experience when you're living
right even when you're not living right
and you can experience that love and
nurture the proper way
but when you think about how disgusting
God is the most disgusted there's only
one true God even though there's all the
gods and power there's nothing like God
he created everything like how
disgusting he is for so many reasons
like and
like
um
the devil
is so powerful too on Earth
something we can't comprehend in the
afterlife
um
I don't want to say the wrong thing
there's a lot of things that I don't
know
um
but I know
that a lot of
intimate things come from the double
and Power
um that can only help me here on Earth
you mentioned before we started that
you're looking for the Illuminati
exactly
um like I have salt like like I said I
have this nasty case of all sorts of
Witchcraft on me like I know this person
and plus like I know I know this person
and very vindictive I and I've known him
for a lot of years enough years and
excuse me
I know enough to know that he has made
me look and feel out to who I am right
now but it's not me and like I can act I
can sing I'm lovable I'm sweet I'm kind
and I'm not fake like I am who I am I
just look disgusting
um living disgusting because of him
and just to say one thing
like
I'm real pissed off at the Illuminati
like I'm real [ __ ] pissed off
like I know my power
and I know who I am and so doesn't the
whole world and I I just don't
understand I can't see
jealousy
or somebody being scared
when of one or two people
when they have a logical explanation of
thinking unless you bring it way back
from years before I wasn't even born
like that would be the only only reason
but like I don't even like like with my
understanding like I I like my heart is
so sweet and understanding and kind but
I'm really pissed off and disgusted like
I want to just ruin
the Illuminati because of the stupidity
like
I don't understand how one person or or
a group of people could be so [ __ ]
stupid to have [ __ ] with God's creation
tell me tell me what you think the
Illuminati is
um from my understanding
um
it's all sorts of like sexy
it's power
it's just like in the mafia except you
have
you have magic and Witchcraft involved
and that's that's one person or a group
oh it's a group of people all you need
is one person because they they they
have it like that yeah and it's here in
Los Angeles
absolutely that's why I'm here where I'm
at and I'm just stuck like I'm on I'm a
person of who I am like yeah but you're
in Skid Row
I don't know anything about California
yeah but I doubt the you know if there
wasn't an Illuminati I doubt they would
be
unskid row I doubt it too very much so
about it
um tell me about your drug use now
um
um I started drinking when I was like
12.
um I thought smoking weed
oh like I did a couple of drugs here and
there from the time I was 15 and then
like I stopped I smoked weed and then I
met like I told you my blind baby daddy
and he's from New York
um
um
and then I just like I walked into I not
for six months I was with him and he
would take off it was just nothing and I
walked into him his father and his
father's wife
smoking crack
and I had did it I had smoked crack one
time before that and it really didn't
want it to me and like I just was like
he's doing it so I want to see what it's
like because I'm a little gullible and
stupid sometimes so I did it and then
so I after like when when I had two kids
on him and I was pregnant in Pawtucket
in Rhode Island and
um he started hitting me in the street
and the cops came and I kind of like was
homeless and then having a way to go so
I started prostituting for the first
time
um
[Music]
so I lost them too
which was everything that's all I ever
wanted was to have kids and like I got
blessed I really got blessed and I just
had a nasty habit
which got in the way but
um
what is your drug know
like here's the thing like I like to die
like I like to do it responsibly and
respectively like get high chill out
drink sleep eat like casually but like
even like I told you even not has gone
into a fan but like I can't get high
normal off weed off ecstasy or any type
of drug
like without just a regular type of high
you know what I'm saying like
everything has been [ __ ] with I can't
go to the bathroom like I can't even go
to the bathroom right and like just go
to the bathroom like a normal human
being it's that embarrassing and like
like I don't understand it like am I
that hated
like Jesus Christ wasn't even that hated
like seriously what drug are you using
currently I'm not I'm so scared like
maybe like five days ago I took a hit a
crack like I want to get high I don't
have money to get high
even if you gave me a hundred thousand
dollars like I know about this
Witchcraft and what it does to me and
when I don't have it and what it does
and what it doesn't do to me like I can
have all the money in the world with the
switchcraft on me and I'm not gonna do
it because I don't want to embarrass
myself
like
I don't know what to do like I have
experience witchcraft before it's a big
thing in my life it's the number one
thing in my life there's nothing else
[ __ ] God [ __ ] the devil and Witchcraft
comes on me from the Devil like
like I don't know how like I just need
to find I can't even look up where to go
like I am not a devil worshiper
and like
but I'm willing to experience everything
from the Devil
like that's my only hope here on Earth
like even though I have faith and
believe in God and I won't put anything
else above God because I'm not stupid
like I know better God's most ultimate
powerful but like I also have an
understanding about what Earth is like
and how could be like and
like I'm really inside I'm really really
scared to death you feel like you're
possessed
I don't feel like I'm possessed
um I just feel I do feel very little
that the devil's in me I have
experienced little feelings that that's
it but like I feel that man
um
is just so been Dick's full
and so like I can't have what I want and
I've been doing this for so long that
like [ __ ] you like I'm gonna take it on
you anyway and it's so stupid because
there's nothing that's so powerful that
has been done to me that's not gonna pay
you back so what the [ __ ] you have done
to me because of who I am like that's
how stupid this whole thing is
like
I I just need to [ __ ] it there's one
thing that I need one thing that I
[ __ ] need and I I already been there
like I'm in Rhode Island
and Massachusetts is the [ __ ] next
state over
Boston I went to the [ __ ] say it's
called the I'm I'm not I'm embarrassed
but I'm gonna say it's called the
satanic temple
and it's also a stupid Museum
so I went there
who I am
and they had an atomy but
I had quarters is in California
so
and you're a church that you [ __ ]
worship the devil like I came all the
way here you already know what time it
makes no sense
so like I I I really don't know what to
do like I I have like all these things I
can do vindictive like that has been
done to me but I'm not that's not in my
nature
like
for a lot of reasons why
but like I'm living on the street on my
[ __ ] birthday I'm Portuguese I'm half
Portuguese I'm like I like a little bit
of white like I got Italian French
Swedish and I got this and I'm not
prejudiced for any type of reason but
like
I have
like on my butt I have been burnt by
black people
like
well then I have been any other person
except for this this dude
and like
um
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear
um
fear
fear itself
I'm scared to death
like
and I just wish I could [ __ ] about
things without being embarrassed about
it and how somebody explained to me
what the [ __ ] I Who I Am for what my
purpose I know what my purpose is here
but I don't
and it's not on the stupidity it just
curiosity and like
my next step to make because I don't
know what to do things that everything
has been stolen from me everything in my
life has been stolen from me
and the only way I know how to get it
back
is the devil
like God has I've gone to church I know
God more than I know the devil
and God hasn't done a [ __ ] thing for
me
I just I I've never been so potently
embarrassed in my [ __ ] life
considerably who I am and even if I
wasn't who I am like how [ __ ]
embarrassing
um
oh
um do you have any cigarette ah yeah
yeah yeah
um
like I look up on my phone like a phone
like tells you everything like a dress
to where the [ __ ] to go like you want to
go here it's right here like there's a
storm where there's a church there's a
[ __ ] whatever and like I'm I'm
strapped my spirit inside of me like you
know what it is can you imagine having
your personality
like strapped down like your brain can't
function right and you know it functions
properly
like you can't do anything like from A
to Z everything that you want to do and
you can do and could possibly do for
everything you can't do it because
you're spiritually strained
like I can't even emotionally get on a
level and cry and like feel the way the
pain
oh
uh
like I'm scared to even like I've been
told from like certain people like
powerful people like how strong my power
is even in my situation that I am now
and I'm even scared I'm scared of that
because
not everybody deserves
like
oh like cruelty and like the nastiness
that could happen
oh my God what's your biggest regret huh
what's your biggest regret
drugs
I has to be drugs because like knowing
all like knowing the things that I know
now would be in my biggest regret like
not taking action about knowing what I
know now
but hands down but like drugs was my
biggest [ __ ] up because my life was just
nastier and nasty when I did drugs
so
where are you staying now
well I came here I was staying in San
Francisco because that's why I was told
to go to reach the headphones Illuminati
and then
oh I even got into you know when they
are down the line they tell everybody
anyone who wants to join Illuminati can
join the Illuminati and they even tell
you you want magic come join you want
Power whatever so I got in touch with
them
and
um
I don't this is what I don't understand
this is the big [ __ ] puzzle
you have this [ __ ] dude has only been
here from when the time he was born and
he's supposed to be this big voodoo King
whatever but Illuminati can change the
way you [ __ ] look your talent
everything about you but this one lean
[ __ ] knows all this voodoo
that's what I'm saying and the
Illuminati has the author saying I knows
who I am for how long have you known
who was supposed to step into the
[ __ ] world at this time
and you don't have back like you don't
have magic you don't have
um protection against a [ __ ] dude
like this like you you knew you had to
have known if you knew who I was you had
to have known all this [ __ ]
so
so like I I I'm in this predicament
where
like I don't even know the spiritual
like personally I don't know one person
from the Illuminati I've never met
anyone
in my travel like in my mind
like a music like I have met some people
but never like and I could only imagine
like
how bad I feel
and look what they've done to me like
they have made me look like a joke
like I have pictures of who I was when I
was a child
and no child
looks one way and then looks disgusting
after that for no reason
like and you had no reason to do that to
me but to embarrass me and you're
convinced the Illuminati is real
absolutely just as real as God and the
devil is absolutely
laughs
I just want to sit down with like I'm 43
years old I just turned 43.
like check this out
um
this is embarrassing but
like everything in my life is
significant
like I have three baby daddies
um like everyone that has been not
everyone but a lot of the significant
people have spiritual names
and like
biblical names that lead me also to
believe who I am
um
like I my I was married and
even like my initials are CD and his
last name is Washington
so like
and I was born it used to be election
day it was November 5th
it's like I know I was supposed to be
born on Election Day you know they
changed it
and
like I know I'm supposed to be this most
beautiful spiritual everything person
and they have taken everything away and
like I don't know what to do like I want
to pun it like I know who I know who
Jesus Christ is and I know like all the
spirituality stuff
laughs
and just for the record
like everything that they have taken
away from me
I want to like like torture
and me
is like I can't put it in a word that I
understand
like hell and the devil can't cover it
like
I'm so [ __ ] stupid pissed off
at stupidity and you [ __ ] stupid
Illuminati
but then I have like this feeling I
don't know if it's a witchcraft hex
feeling or if it's me being genuine with
understanding with something I can't
even understand
like
I've never seen something so [ __ ]
beautiful and sweet like I've seen
adorable sweet but like from who I am as
a person like
compared to what you can't compare that
like
they have made me so [ __ ] disgusting
like
I I just don't I don't know what to do
like I I can't even like I can sing like
I can sing my ass off like I really can
and like they have done so many bad
things to me
I can't even find on my [ __ ] phone
where to go to Hollywood to first of all
to find a place to sing second of all to
feel comfortable enough and sing
or to like I don't know what to do like
I'm stuck
all I want to do is find a [ __ ]
powerful
devil worshiping church and do some
[ __ ] witchcraft
and like they're so scared the
Illuminati is so scared
because
like you reap what you sow right
it says it right there you you you you
do witchcraft it tells you you don't do
something to somebody unless you at
least get it back and return to you it's
a rule it's like a golden rule
so
like it makes no sense
you know like I could never do that
especially who I am even if I knew I had
it like that the feeling of doing
something like that to somebody
especially who doesn't deserve it just
with some stupid [ __ ] like one
little [ __ ] thing
like you can't compare that
you can't throw all this nastiness that
I have been through like because
I did I got tricked or somebody got
tricked into doing one little [ __ ]
stupid thing that created a lot of
nastiness like
oh and I understand that too but like
um
I don't know what to do
like I'm just
I I need to I need to find this [ __ ]
church so bad
ah
a
I'm gonna start off
but I hear that and I know that there's
hope like I'm supposed to see like I
know
that Christmas is supposed to be a gift
I like
if I could have one gift it would just
be to be like really happy it's
something that I had never been
probably since I was a child and
probably don't even remember that
but I know that this [ __ ] Illuminati
has a hold on me
which would be the only [ __ ] hope
and it's not like I'm some girl off the
streets that's talking [ __ ] because of
who I am that's the uh you know the only
difference
but like I know they have like this like
I've seen Pitch a whole bunch of
pictures of people in the Illuminati
like rap artists
actresses excuse me actors who have gone
from
ugly
or just normal looking to like banging
looking like sexy as a [ __ ] and
I know it's not plastic surgery like
like even if it was plastic surgery with
the money you have you know like I have
hope
but like I'm so confused and it's not
like I'm gullible and stupid it's just
because I'm being told all these
different things about
like
like it's the end of the world right
like we just had the [ __ ] Coronavirus
right it took out I don't know I I'm
pretty sure because I'm not too [ __ ]
educated on it but like almost probably
a little less than half the world
a good portion of it
and I'm pretty [ __ ] significant to
who I am and everybody knows it like and
I'm not even
like it's embarrassing to say but I'm
not I'm like 0.1 to what I'm supposed to
be who I am without this [ __ ] on me
and
that's how nervous and scared and I
can't even like think of the word of
when I do step like things have been
everything's been taken away from me
like I have everyone has like a soulmate
like and I've Been Told
like
I've been told that
I have I won't like go into it too much
but like I've been told I have this
special person
and he's taken away from me from the
Illuminati
which means everything so much worse
but like he has all this
magic and he can't do anything for me I
don't know I'm just I'm scared to like I
don't know
I don't I really don't know what I'm
getting at huh
I just know that I'm super special
and all these good things
and I just don't know how to get there I
I I don't know what to do
oh Chrissy all I can tell you is Skid
Row is probably not to not the way you
get there no I know I I know that
foreign
Witchcraft and black black magic that
shouldn't have been done in this
situation
like not these type of things like
different things I can understand but
now look at the world
like I didn't even know what was
happening like
I got involved with somebody back in
Rhode Island that took me off I had a
nasty crack habit and he talked me out
of like a situation helped me out
a nice dream in my life for a big time
more than ever in my life
and like I was in love
and like that didn't even work out
so like
I don't know I'm stuck I'm stuck I need
advice
some serious advice
huh
it's stupid because anyone anyone that
can [ __ ] it's got that third eye that
that Illuminati sees
and like they can see who I am I just
don't I don't know
I don't want to complain too much
all right Chrissy yeah thank you you're
welcome thank you for sharing your story
you're welcome I hope you find what
you're looking for yeah me too
but I can guarantee you it's not down
here in Skid Row I know I got a little
[ __ ] Hollywood
everybody [ __ ] knows that I'm not
sure that's the answer either
right right yeah I know
you might be a little confused huh I
think you might be a little confused as
to what the answer might be
what do you think the answer is you
think the Illuminati or Voodoo or any of
the things you're considering or are the
answer
so then what else would it be
well I mentioned huh getting getting
clean off a crack might might help
no my phone not being hacked would help
okay
laughs
all right John thank you very much so
you have this in my pocket you gotta get
this one